do you think it's fair to criticize
Democrats for taking money from Harvey
Weinstein this is my feeling about that
like take the money I mean it's already
it's the hardest fact that's right I
think this whole thing with USC and they
gave a big a they're giving back the
money that he gave for women filmmakers
likes keep it like where is it gonna go
to the board to the company that's
already failure healing I like money I
don't care who knows J James Carville do
you think that Democrat Doug Jones has a
good chance to beat Roy Moore in Alabama
if you don't know Roy Moore is a Big Ten
Commandments guy he's actually nine he
doesn't bleed in the seventh about
stealing just you know fifty G's for
nine you can't eat them you know you got
two people to hotel he starts a
foundation he raises money for these
poor people gets a tax exemption and
then he pays all the money to he and his
wife and then when they're out of money
they mortgaged a building in downtown
Montgomery to pay him more so I don't
know but I think there are there are
some people who believe that thou shalt
not steal thing I think even atheists
believe that you shouldn't steal I think
everybody we believe it for I'm a
lesbian they don't need only two of the
commandments our laws around steal and
don't kill which we can figure out on
our own
the other ones are about you know don't
build a statue and the people of Alabama
think that washington needs another
thief then they should send roar more
right there not enough thieves in
Washington Roy Moore believes that not
standing for the anthem is against the
law did you see that he said that it
said it's the law that we have to stand
for the ends have been put our hand on
all right this yes he's a just fourth
commandment thou shalt stand for them
Eric Erickson do you think Steve Bannon
will be effective finding candidates to
primary congressional Republicans
finding more control finding them to
primary yes finding them to win and I'm
not so sure we've got the one who was in
jail the one who believes in Kim trails
I'm not sure if the one who believes in
UFOs is one of his and you know they may
very well beat some of the Republican
establishment guys and honestly a lot of
the Republican establishment guys I
think deserve to be beaten because them
campaigning and breaking promises got
the bay so pissed off that's what led
him to burn the party down with Trump so
they kind of deserve it but then they're
gonna lose to the Democrats in the
general election you run the felon or
the chemtrails lady they're not going to
win the general you have a lot of
influence with those voters what do you
tell them about it listen I said don't
vote for Trump they didn't listen to me
what do you tell them about an issue
like health care where like I think you
know I've read that many like the
Affordable Care Act but they don't like
Obama care many of them you know I think
I probably have been saved by it you
know Trump called Obamacare this week a
disgrace which is such a disgrace to
court I mean maybe you don't agree with
a little bit it's not a disgrace and
again James where are the Democrats to
see end up full-throated Lee and saying
this is our signature achievement first
of all every Democrat voted against
repeal and replace
okay the Democrats everything passed it
by one vote they voted for it I mean
would you want the Democrat you know all
the rest do is talk about all the lot
you know the demo if the Democrats what
are you saying is gonna get you very far
in an in a democratic party they'll all
come out and would work if you said that
tax cuts create surpluses as they do you
just can't do that that you're you're a
Democrat you can't run against
immigrants you just can't do it if you
did you wouldn't be a Democrat it's just
the nature of who you are you can't
believe that that global warming is a
hoax because you're just just in your in
your DNA it's who you are right you
they don't think that way they're still
sitting there after the disaster in
Kansas after after the whole thing they
really are trying to tell people that if
you cut the estate tax you're gonna grow
the economy Rick you can't say no no
person can say that but Steve minuchin
can say it who cares so how you
pronounce his name I think they might be
a bit up there already
Margaret what do you think of Jeff
Sessions sending a Justice Department
lawyer to prosecute the murder of a
trans teen in Iowa you know actually no
because I followed this and I you know I
work in a space and one would think well
maybe this is interesting maybe there's
a change of heart with Jeff Sessions but
I'm suspicious I'm curious I don't know
why he's doing it this is a man who
doesn't have a good record of standing
up for the individuals the rights of
LGBT Americans this is a man who advised
the Education Department to rescind the
guidelines for transgender students he's
not somebody who doesn't believe it's a
real thing that people have gender
dysmorphia so I I'm concerned actually
because I'm the on the surface the
headline reads really well oh he's
investigating it maybe maybe you know
they'll find out you know does this this
actually was a really a hate crime or a
crime of intolerance and I suspect that
there are worse forces at play here I
don't go back to you think about the
Democrats being being so weak they go
these people are put in fact people the
good Kessler to all of these people they
document this and it's overwhelming the
number of lives that they call not that
people don't care they don't care and if
you ask yourself this why go back and
look at how many special counsels
independent prosecutors etc etc or
Republicans you know how many are all of
them because if a Republican is under
investigation if we can't have a
Democrat investigating different
Democrat is under investigations that we
can't have a Democrat basket and you
know what all of the Democratic
establishment the editorial writers the
commentators to everything say oh yes
you have never why is there never a
democratic independent council ever
because the cousins because we just
accept the fact that they will raise
hell and not pay attention to what a
Democrat says that you are right to a
point but when you get to the point to
say what we need to do is lie as much as
they do our people not a lot of data
what the size is not exactly equivalent
to lying okay we're talking about the
political right we're not talking about
the policy room I'm talking about next
time so when they take polls they always
say people will say they trust the
Republican Party more to defend us that
they're the daddy party and let's put a
chip in that because you know when John
Kerry ran they went there right yeah
we'll put up a war hero so they can't
but they go there and we don't go there
[Applause]